are we going to allow
a.i to decide who lives and who dies if
we can't even draw the line there and
say that no we're not going to allow ai
to be built to anonymously murder
anybody who are we kidding if we think
we're going to be able to
exclude any uses of ai we've already
seen real world use cases of these
weapons types and we're seeing reports
of development and use of these weapons
at an accelerating rate so we decided to
make a film
to illustrate very clearly that the
issue is you make these autonomous
weapons you can launch them
uh by the million or the 10 million
and wipe out entire human populations
quite deliberately and that makes as
much sense as selling nuclear weapons in
a supermarket
so the film is structured in three parts
the first part of the film is to remind
us of the risks of these types of
weapons and to illustrate the end point
that we are rapidly driving towards with
today's technological developments what
we see there is a world in which
autonomous weapons have proliferated
outside of military hands and into the
hands of non-state actors civilians and
police forces alike the second part of
the film talks about the rhetoric and
the thinking and the technological
developments that we're already seeing
today that are driving us towards that
end point with autonomous weapons and
the third part of the film
aims to show us what can we do about
this how can we mitigate this risk by
acting today and that is based on the
real world policy proposal that has been
outlined by the icrc by the red cross
and that is slated to be debated by the
u.n at a meeting later this december and
this part of the film aims to be hopeful
it aims to show us that we can still act
to mitigate this risk we can draw a red
line on a prohibition of autonomous
weapon systems that are designed or used
to target people
it also shows us that we can set a
powerful precedent by steering ai in a
direction towards safe and ethical use
my name is stuart russell
i'm a professor of computer science at
the university of california berkeley
i've been doing artificial intelligence
for more than 40 years i'm max tegmark
a professor doing ai research at mit
and also
the president and
one of the founders of the future life
institute
hi i'm dr emilia javorsky and i am a
physician a scientist and an
entrepreneur i believe that artificial
intelligence can
help life flourish like never before
if
the wisdom with which we manage it grows
faster than its power now the key
to having this huge upside from
artificial intelligence is going to be
to make sure that we don't pervert this
technology
into
destabilizing stupid uses i feel a
particular responsibility to make sure
that ai is used for good
and
banning autonomous weapons
is one of the best things we can do to
make sure that happens i work with the
future of life institute which is a
non-profit organization focused on
mitigating the risks of powerful
technologies
over the past few years i have been
leading our efforts on the topic of
lethal autonomous weapon systems that's
why i'm so excited to share with you if
human kill
we are live with brett power on the line
where police are now confirming a
drive-by shooting at a polling station
they're all in a line shot in the head
just where they stood the whole line is
dead the line is dead looks like some
voters had children with them
all spared not even her brett local pd
are saying a suspicious device may have
been discovered
could this be slaughterbots
[Applause]
i see police i see some officers
deploying camouflage masks right now
we're on the move police are interested
in an abandoned vehicle they're heavily
camouflaged now wait there's there's
another vehicle and another vehicle
across the street they seem quite
concerned about that
look out
the cops are down
[Music]
yet another national security crisis for
this administration
everybody was dancing and then suddenly
we look
horrible
the world in which we fail to draw a red
line on autonomous weapons means that
the types of things we see and hear in
part one of this film will be
really imminently upon us i hear clearly
one political party has decided
that by attacking
uh pole lines in areas that the other
political party dominates
they can scare people away from the
polls and win elections that way
we're already seeing
drug cartels using remotely controlled
drones
to assassinate members of opposing
cartels
it's very likely that they
would use these weapons if they were
widely manufactured and available they
would use these weapons to carry out
their
their campaigns of terror
against the military against the police
against civilian populations and against
each other this scene highlights that
lethal tolerance weapons are a weapon of
mass destruction
in that it enables very few
to kill very many because they don't
require human supervision
to carry out the attack if you wanted to
use a million remotely piloted drones uh
to kill everyone in afghanistan you
would need a million pilots and another
15 million support personnel to manage
all those weapons
but with fully autonomous weapons with
slaughterbots
you only need one or two people to
define the mission
and release the weapons people who think
we can avoid immoral things being done
with slaughterbots by putting in some
sort of ethics chip into it
forget that
the person who determines what's morally
good and morally bad is the owner of the
slaughterbot will might decide that
everybody with this skin color is bad
and should be killed
robots have no moral conscious of their
own they'll just do exactly as they're
told the technology is able to overcome
the countermeasures used by the police
which are special camouflage mosques to
hide the fact that they're human beings
um but the slaughterbots
seem to be able to evade this
countermeasure actually
to recognize the police as as
targets even though they're wearing the
camouflage mask so this points to the
fact that
these weapons can evolve very quickly
to defeat counter measures
they can be reprogrammed because it's
only a software question it's not a
matter of redesigning the hardware
so you can reprogram them overnight
to defeat a countermeasure the tech that
was used in the slaughter bots in this
scene
had three
components the targeting
the killing
and the flying the flying is just
trivial quite a little quadcopter gps
can control
the
killing
it's very easy to do with a very low low
weight explosive for example
the targeting is something you already
have in your smartphone where you it
looks at you and unlocks because it
recognizes your face
it's quite easy to
use face recognition to instead just say
hey is this a child that we should spare
or is an adult we should kill
maybe
you look at the skin color of the person
and use that to decide who you're going
to kill
the autonomous weapon operates a bit
like a chess program which decides where
to move the pieces and which of the
enemy pieces to kill
so it's not a mysterious spooky emergent
consciousness thing
it's the same type of autonomy that our
chess programs and go programs and other
game playing programs have had for
decades all the tech needed for this
already exists
and it's just a matter of integrating it
and mass producing it i think the number
one reason why lethal thomas weapons
haven't already been banned is just a
bunch of misconceptions about what they
are on many occasions
national governments and senior defense
officials have talked about
the only problem
with autonomous weapons is what happens
if they become conscious
and decide that they hate human beings
and start killing us at random
right um i've talked to
senior defense officials who literally
said
that they have talked to their expert
advisors
and they've been assured that skynet
uh the uh this conscious computer system
that directed the terminators uh in the
terminator films that skynet is not a
real possibility uh and so we don't need
to worry about any of these bad
scenarios
the german government said that a weapon
is not autonomous
unless it is fully self-aware
so when you have defense officials and
governments
talking complete nonsense uh about
a subject of such international
importance
we felt uh that we had failed
the word lethal in lethal thomas weapons
means that they kill humans
so
an automatic uh
anti-aircraft missile for example or
anti-tank missile is not
a lethal weapon because it shoots at a
tank
and an aircraft and
a lethal thomas weapon will only kill
people that are not sitting inside of
tanks
that are just walking around
doing their thing that's why their dream
come true for criminals and terrorists
who want to wipe out a certain ethnic
group say the word autonomous
and least thomas weapons means that it's
the algorithm itself that decides who
lives and who dies
which means that cruise missiles for
instance are not
lethal autonomous weapons but and nor
are the drones that are remote
controlled because in both cases the
decision about what the target is made
by a human being and finally
many people think of
terminator
or some sort of
two-legged robot
when they think about lethal weapons
which is pretty useless from a military
point of view but what's much more
popular
in its effectiveness are flying things
in swarms or alone little um things like
you'll see in our film
and various other types of embodiments
that look absolutely nothing like
a two-legged arnold schwarzenegger
no no no killer robots marching down the
street that can't happen
these are professional munitions and
they aren't just gonna fall into the
hands of bad guys we're building really
robust procedures whole constellation of
products at the trade show this year
this is an industry energized by last
year's successes devices apparently
hunted down and killed soldiers who were
regrouping after fleeing the battlefield
of course they can't target kids in the
street they are hard coded to target men
in the battle space that surely mean men
and women well sure it can be added to
the target profile purely a military
device for confronting military
aggression nobody is endorsing civilian
applications the second such autonomous
assassination of leading scientists big
win for regional powers as they hope to
[ __ ] their neighbor's nuclear program
the design obstacles are dropping like
dominoes we are getting more lethal more
versatile more affordable so we can
empower more customers regime change
without the billion dollar spend or the
body bags a real lift to the smallest
armies legitimate armies though not sure
but who are we to decide who they are
the second section of this film is
really aimed to mirror what we're seeing
happening today now these might seem a
little over the top and exaggerated but
this is modeled on the real world
rhetoric that we've even heard in our
discussions with diplomats and people
who are in favor of developing these
types of weapons this idea that don't
worry we'll build robust verification
procedures yes proliferation is an issue
and escalation is an issue but we'll
deal with that when the time comes so
i've heard the argument that autonomous
weapons won't fall into the hands of the
bad guys it's like saying well let's
build machine guns and of course
criminals will never ever get access to
machine guns crime gangs will never have
them but we know for a fact that that's
not true proliferation is pretty much
inevitable when you have weapons that
are really cheap and really small for
example the united states
simply lost 200 000
ar-15 automatic rifles in iraq
they have no idea where they went
uh there are a hundred million
kalashnikovs in private hands
the stm cargo drone
which is produced by a government-owned
corporation in turkey
was sold to one of the factions in the
libya conflict despite the presence of a
very strict united nations arms embargo
so in fact there appears to be
very few controls if any on the
proliferation of these weapons so the
way this will work is that arms
manufacturers
produce large quantities of weapons they
go to trade fairs all over the world
many of them completely unregulated or
taking place
in countries like north korea or syria
where
there are really no controls
on who gets what
and then arms dealers buy them they pass
from through shell companies
to
drug gangs
to
human smugglers
uh
to factions fighting in civil wars to
terrorist groups
um and all of these groups are extremely
well armed um and you can be absolutely
sure that they are not manufacturing
those weapons by themselves
slaughterbots is just a tiny fraction of
all the
militarily useful things you can do with
ai weapons
so the arms industry will be just fine
if you ban them but if we don't ban them
of course they're going to sell those
too
the only reason they wouldn't is if
they're illegal
like bioweapons
the balance of power
is an interesting question in this
debate
uh do we want
to tip the balance of power away from
the major powers
who have
long histories of
learning to abide by constraints on the
use of military power
and tip the balance in favor of rogue
nations
non-state actors
who are
able to act in ways that are completely
unconstrained by
moral or political or economic
consequences of their actions
i think it's inevitable
that the development of these weapons
would reduce international security for
pretty much every country
they're largely
effective as
weapons of attack and not as weapons of
defense
the particular concern that i have is
the small anti-personnel weapon the
the so-called swarm weapon
which
could be extremely effective not just
against uh
for example
infantry formations but also against
human populations civilian populations
autonomous weapons in many ways make
ideal tools for assassination uh you can
be hundreds of miles away when the
attack takes place
uh it can be completely unattributable
um and all the security measures that
are currently taken for example to
protect political figures
would be useless because
you don't require line of sight
you don't have to have somebody with a
sniper rifle hold up in a hotel
that has direct line of sight to the
politician
so um i know for a fact that
the fear of assassination
is
uppermost in the minds of many
governments
as they think about the risks of
autonomous weapons and we only have to
think back to world war one
which was precipitated by the
assassination of archduke ferdinand
that once you get into tit-for-tat
assassinations and politicians
you can very quickly
uh devolve into a full-scale war
i think another important point is that
delegating the decision to kill humans
to an algorithm
is a deliberate devaluing of human life
the
people that i've spoken to in the
military take that responsibility
extremely seriously
and handing it over to an algorithm and
saying
i can't be bothered to worry about it
i'm not going to put myself at risk
we're just going to have the algorithm
do all the killing
is a complete abdication of
responsibility
and puts the value of human life
far lower than it should be the other
idea that we could just have wars where
only
robots die
doesn't really make sense at all
if you could prosecute a war
and win
without any human casualties on either
side
then you might as well play baseball or
tiddlywinks to decide who wins the war
in a real war
one side only surrenders when the amount
of damage inflicted
on their populations their
uh control infrastructure
uh their um their factories
um their cities becomes unsustainable
uh and that's true whether the damage is
being inflicted by robots or by human
soldiers so another one of the big
concerns about autonomous weapons is
accidental escalation of warfare
so
if you have fully autonomous defense
systems that can retaliate
against what is perceived as an attack
then you could imagine this happening
even without a real attack
on several occasions in the history of
nuclear weapons for example
our early detection systems have
detected a nuclear attack that wasn't
actually happening it was only human
intervention that prevented a full-scale
nuclear war from taking place
the reason that we chose to make ifhuman
kill was to
pick up where slaughterbots 1 left off
slaughterbots one warned us of an
emerging risk that we were going to face
when we presented
slaughterbots at the ccw in 2017
many people dismissed it as science
fiction for example the russian
ambassador
said why are we even discussing this
this is 25 or 30 years in the future
it's just science fiction
um
but when we presented it to people in
the ai community
as they were watching the ceo
demonstrating the weapon and talking
about its use for mass attacks
uh the ai researchers thought that this
was a real video not a fictional
presentation but this was a real
recording of a real ceo
so they obviously considered the
technology to be entirely feasible
meanwhile
a turkish company called stm
was preparing the public announcement
for their weapon the cargo autonomous
drone
which was announced about three weeks
after we presented the video
and advertised as having the capability
for autonomous hits
using face recognition and human
tracking cargo drones from the turkish
stm company were used in libya to hunt
down fleeing humans according to a
united nations report and we just don't
know whether these were soldiers or
whether there were some random
libyan truck drivers have been
contractor or what then the company
obviously is not sharing any information
with us at the time a lot of people were
like ah forget it they're decades and
decades away well they were wrong
because now they're already here
and so the next part of the story for us
was to talk about what is the kind of
thinking that is fueling our development
of these weapons and moving towards that
horrific endpoint that was shown in
slaughterbots one but more importantly
what is it that we can do about it to
avert that outcome and how can we really
take this opportunity of autonomous
weapons not only to avert a really dire
outcome for humanity but also help steer
ai and set a powerful precedent for how
ai can be used for good and be used
safely and ethically and this idea of a
red line and drawing a red line as a
global community that machines must
never decide who lives and who dies is
is really a first step in that direction
all right now we're going to cross the
u.n where we're told the treaty has now
been signed
generations before us thought that
future wars would be fought with toxic
chemicals
and infectious germs
they thought our landscapes would be
littered with unexploded landlines
and more recently it seemed inevitable
we were on a course to mass produce a
new class of merciless autonomous
weapons which use algorithms to decide
who to kill
we knew the dangers
but we thought we had no choice
because we thought our enemies were too
inhuman to respect innocent lives
we thought
if we didn't
they would
[Applause]
[Music]
but each time we feared the worst
we were wrong
together our nations have ratified a new
legally binding treaty
together we prohibit weapons which
select human targets and attack without
human control
[Music]
[Applause]
humanity must prevail on the battlefield
and from today
it will
[Music]
so the third section of the film at its
most literal level is a fictionalized
version of the real world policy
proposal for autonomous weapons that is
currently being debated and so that's at
the heart of what the fictionalized
secretary general is saying in in this
speech is imagining what would our world
look like on the day that we actually
agreed to a treaty on autonomous weapons
so in this last scene we see the drone
come in and is looming overhead and
given all we've experienced up until
this point we assume that it's going to
make the decision of who to kill of
these two humans locked in this complex
standoff
but it doesn't
it de-escalates the situation and both
people make it out alive
to me the drone represents our hopeful
future with technology where it is used
not to undermine our humanity but to
build on it and to advance it
in the earlier parts of the film we see
human beings through the lens of
technology as code in screens
and through cameras but in this part of
the film we revert to a cinematic style
of filmmaking to really illuminate the
human element and to know that human
beings are not just sensor data we're
human beings and in this scene we see a
tense standoff between two individuals
who are trying to navigate the
complexity of one another's humanity in
impossible circumstances of war
and what this scene really says to me
and what we see in the trade-offs and
the dynamics between these two
individuals is that there are certain
elements of being human and navigating
the humanity of another that will never
be a capability of an algorithm or of a
machine we start out with if human kill
and we end at if human protect
the kill protect dichotomy is really
representative of the options that lie
before us for our future with ai
there are very few outcomes to be
imagined where our future with ai is
incremental or middle of the road it's
either going to be one which is
flourishing and incredible and advances
our humanity or one that is very dark
and destabilizing and undermines it
and so this is the decision that's
before us today
here with autonomous weapons is the
first step which one are we going to
choose to kill
or to protect if we can't even agree
that
we don't want to
let people legally build and sell
ai systems that can on their own go off
and decide who to kill and kill them i
mean who are we kidding that we're ever
going to
draw the line anywhere right whereas if
we can win that battle
we've set the precedent that there are
some things that are off limit
and we can steer this amazing technology
towards a future
that i think we will all be
really really excited to find ourselves
in so this film is really timely in that
while it's a work of fiction it's
something that is illuminating a very
very real world and applied
circumstances that we're chatting
through today
it also is helping us to ground in
what's ahead
and as we think towards global action on
this issue we have this amazing
opportunity which is a once in five-year
meeting of the un in december to debate
this issue specifically and we have this
incredible moment in which we can draw
this red line and mitigate this risk of
autonomous weapons and so that for us
was key in developing this film was we
wanted to be able to remind people that
this risk is here and but there's still
something we can do about it if we act
now
so the policy prescription for
autonomous weapons there is a great
piece that has been put forth by the
icrc which is the international
committee of the red cross
it's an independent organization and
they're largely seen as the custodians
of the law of war and their policy
proposal has three pillars the first
being a prohibition a legally binding
prohibition that's important on systems
with high degrees of unpredictable
behavior the second which is the policy
proposal that we explore in the film is
a legally binding prohibition on
autonomous weapons that are designed or
used to target humans
and the last one is the need to develop
regulations on other types of autonomous
weapons so you can think of that class
as sort of an autonomous fighter jet
against autonomous fighter jet where the
target is not actually a human being and
these three pillars are to be debated by
the un at the meeting in december as to
whether or not to act and take these up
so a key element of a policy
prescription for a lethal autonomous
weapons in this icrc position
is the idea of a legally binding
instrument right legally binding means
new law a new treaty now this is
important because that does not mean a
political declaration or a political
promise or some strong statement there
really is when we look throughout the
history of disarmament affairs
no
more important tool than a legally
binding instrument in order to exert a
real meaningful effect on the behavior
of states and also generating a
diplomatic and social stigma around a
class of weapons we've seen this before
with land mines we've seen it with bio
weapons with chemical weapons
legally binding is is central to
whatever sort of path forward we take
so there are plenty of historical
examples of where legally binding
treaties were used to mitigate the risks
of powerful technologies the bioweapons
ban the chemical weapons ban bans on
blinding lasers the list goes on the
bioweapons ban in particular is one that
we really see as a great example for the
future with autonomous weapons the
bioweapons ban took the weaponization of
biology and germ warfare off of the
table and that unlocked biology as a
field to be one that we associate with
new medicines curing diseases and
transforming agriculture that's the fate
that we hope a new legally binding
instrument will have for artificial
intelligence by avoiding its
weaponization we will unlock its
positive potential to steer us towards a
similarly flourishing future for the
science the argument that
autonomous weapons have a high degree of
military effectiveness and therefore
no one's going to agree to ban them
probably isn't
true
chemical weapons were quite effective in
world war one
if you read the
the memoir of the russian gentleman who
was
in charge of a large part of their
biological weapons program
in the
60s 70s 80s
he believes that russian use of
biological weapons in world war ii was
uh extremely important
in helping to defeat the germans
and so
there's no doubt that the us and russia
believed biological weapons were a very
very important
part of their defense programs
and yet
we were able to ban them the argument
that was used initially
in the u.s by biologists and chemists
was that if these weapons become
widely available they will be cheap
effective weapons of mass destruction
that will proliferate
to non-state actors to rogue nations to
smaller countries
and tip the balance of power
away from the major powers
and
thereby reducing the security of the
united states
that argument was persuasive to richard
nixon
who unilaterally
abandoned the u.s biological weapons
program not because it was ineffective
but because it would become effective
and if that happened would reduce the
security of the united states so are we
doomed right is our fate sealed with
autonomous weapons and we should all
just invest in a bunker now there's many
reasons why you may sincerely want to
invest in a bunker but i sincerely
believe that autonomous weapons should
not be one of them and so with this film
we really aim to show that
yes action is possible this is what it
could look like and this is why we need
to do it now
so what is it that you can do about
autonomous weapons learn more about it
you can find out more by going to
autonomousweapons.org
if you want the future free of slaughter
bots please share this film on social
media and please make sure that
the people who are going to be making
these decisions actually understand how
much you care about this because this is
an incredibly important
watershed uh and try uh to
uh move your country your fellow
citizens
in the direction of supporting a treaty
if you are a journalist
you have an enormous opportunity to
actually influence what happens
to get the happy ending we saw in this
film the main reason
that this hasn't been solved already is
because
these perspectives are almost never made
available to the broader public
and therefore the decision makers never
hear from the broader public about the
need to actually do something about it
if you are
a person who works in artificial
intelligence you should know that
the vast majority of your colleagues
already support this idea of banning
lethal thomas weapons we've done a lot
of work at fli to develop both open
letters and pledges to never develop or
work on these systems and to support the
kind of regulation that is being put
forth by the icrc so please make your
voice heard
and don't let the few rotten eggs you
know ruin the reputation of your field
for you
the same way that biologists stood up
and said hey we want biology to stand
for saving lives make sure that your
field gets remembered as
a field that helps find new solutions
not uh the field that
kind of ruined our open society with
slaughter bots and if you're a member of
the diplomatic community it's time to
act it's time to adopt these types of
policy frameworks that are clear that
are concise and that are ready to go and
so encouraging bold action from our
policy makers is really what the world
needs today so at present
the topic of autonomous weapons is being
discussed at the ccw in geneva
the ccw process
is a consensus process so it requires
essentially every nation to go along
with an agreement to have a discussion
uh to go along with drafting the terms
of a treaty uh and to agree to the
treaty
an alternative is the un general
assembly which doesn't require unanimity
and i think that would reflect better
the interests of the people of the world
who over and over again in polls have
shown that they are
very strongly opposed to the development
of these kinds of weapons
if you are part of the united nations
ccw process
then please vote no
in december to any extension of the
ccw's mandate beyond this year unless
there's a clear
resolution to ban
lethal autonomous weapons otherwise the
ccw is not part of the solution it's
just standing in the way of the solution
preventing this issue from going to a
different form
that can actually handle it
and give us the ban that we need
steering the future of technology is
hard but it's worth doing because the
upside if we get it right is just
tremendous